I haven't the faintest idea why I agreed
to this
I must be functioning copy prick can you
help us with this bill Bernardo near the
bubble working sorry is this gonna work
hey dick Ababu a to a Nandita thank God
he's found something your droids
forbidden memory bank words translated
from sis that's it yeah that's what we
need who are you hanging out with it
speaks sin can you make him triple Babu
can you make him translate it
valedictory yes but it will cause a
complete mandate memory what Lily we
make him translate if you won't remember
anything good I remember I go black oh
there must be some other way there's an
aren't you back up your memory please
our two storage units are famously
unreliable you know the odds better than
any of us do we have choice
[Music]
if this mission fails it was all for
nothing or we've done all this time
we're doing there in three bill taking
one last look sir
at my friends
[Music]
nitrates are gonna start soon I'll keep
lookout come on with you you still don't
trust me huh did you ever trust me nope
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
man
but the one I have to do but I don't
know if I have the strength to do it
[Music]
you know
dad
I know
[Music]
[Applause]
that's something my sister would want
you to have
[Music]
it was the last night of her training
[Music]
laya told me that she had since the
death of her son at the end of her Jedi
past she surrendered her saber to me and
said that one day it would be picked up
again by someone who would finish her
journey
a thousand generations live in you now
but this is your fight
do it make the sacrifice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what we've done
all this time
I want you to know that you have been a
real friend of to my best one in fact
[Music]
before
Ross together
[Music]
I will manage erotic started
[Music]
thousand generations live in you now
this is your destiny
[Music]
with you boys
[Music]
you